I am joined with my partner in crime today Paul Scheer.
Yes.
All right, let's share
some of the stories that we're thankful for
and we're gonna be making actually hand turkeys
while we do this, right Paul?
Okay, I love it.
I got my construction paper,
I got my scissors,
I stole my kid's markers right off his desk.
Perfect, and what I'm gonna say
is my favorite thing to do every Thanksgiving,
which is (mimicking turkey gobbling).
I can't do that. (mimicking turkey gobbling).
There you go (mimicking turkey gobbling).
There you go, all right, I feel pretty good.
Okay, our first story,
a few weeks back KTVT in Dallas
reported that a 14 year old, Anika --,
won a $25,000 prize for developing
a possible treatment for COVID-19.
Anika used biomedical software to design a molecule
that could stop the function of the proteins in coronavirus.
At 14!
Anika, oh my gosh, wow.
When I was 14 I was trying to beat Sonic the Hedgehog.
This is next level,
I mean, this is what we need.
Ah, that gives me like hope
for humanity and the future and, wow.
She's gonna save us all.
Paul, what's your story?
Drew, did you know that there is a town
that has a dog as its mayor?
That's right.
What?
Yes, this town has a French bulldog as a mayor.
And I got to read you some of the stats here.
Over 44,000 people voted for this mayor,
and you may think he ran on a platform
of give me liberty or give me milk bones,
but he actually ran on a platform
of mental health and breast cancer awareness.
So this dog is doing a lot of good work.
He knocked out Brenneth Paltrow
which was the dog that was in beforehand.
And what's actually really amazing about this
is it costs money to vote in this election.
And the reason why it cost money is it's for charity.
So they are raising charity.
So that's really amazing,
they're raising charity for mental health awareness.
I love this story.
Now this is politics we can get behind.
Okay, this next story actually comes from Toronto.
CBC reports that a carpenter named Khalil Sevewright
is building insulated shelters
for homeless people in the community.
And his designs work off body heat,
which keeps it around 60 degrees in the winter.
And the shelters aren't authorized by the city,
but Khalil says
that they're a temporary solution for survival.
This is wonderful.
This is the kind of stuff I need to hear.
Absolutely, I mean, it makes me incredibly emotional.
By the way, I am a little worried about my hand turkey.
I don't know if I'm doing this well.
I'm also trying to make a bow tie,
and what it really looks like is like pinwheels.
It doesn't look like a bow tie at all.
Drew, I'm impressed with your Turkey.
You have a lot more props than I have.
You're not gonna,
my turkey is sad.
Okay, Paul, I'm so sorry.
Did you have another story?
You know, this has been,
like you said, a really a tough year.
And I found this article on New York Magazine's website,
they have this thing called The Strategist,
and it was all about how to take better photos.
And they have these amazing classes
that you could take from your house.
It'll teach you how to do Photoshop,
it will teach you
how to go out in the street and take pictures,
and for me,
since we haven't been able
to get out of the house that much,
or we're doing it in limited time,
I'm just now bringing my camera around
and I'm just taking pictures of my kids and my wife
and I feel like I would never have made time
for that amount of learning.
So I'm thankful for that
and I think a lot of people are out there doing all of that.
Well, I don't know what this is, Paul, but--
I love it.
Yours, I look at it and I'm like, oh, it's a turkey.
This I look at and I'm like, "What the heck is that?"
Did we just fail kindergarten, Drew?
Did we just fail out?
That's my second time doing that,
so that's fine.
And you know what?
I'm still here.
So, Paul Scheer, everyone.
Your documentary, by the way, "Marvel 616".
Yeah, I have a documentary.
It's gonna be on Disney Plus.
It's a part of this a series of eight short films,
they're about an hour each,
and it covers an area of Marvel.
And I basically came to a realization
that to make it in Hollywood
I have to attach myself to a Marvel character.
So I go on a deep dive
of finding the weirdest characters in the Marvel universe.
They'll make you cry, they'll make you laugh,
and they'll make you inspired.
Yeah, no, it looks incredible.
I'm so excited for it,
and I'm so excited to hang out with you here.
Doing the news with you with the best.
And again, your backdrop is sublime.
So are you and your whole family and thank you so much.
We'll see you soon.
Bye bye.
Thank you, Paul.
(upbeat music)